all right guys this is the one from new
rock stars i've been waiting for
i'm just so curious like i have my own
theories of how quick silver is back in
one division i'm sure a lot of us do
but i'm just so curious to see if ea
vos eric the voss is able to accurately
predict it if anyone can it's here hey
if anyone can do it it's this guy let's
see what's in store baby
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division just officially
crossed over
x-men to the marvel cinematic universe
and no one knows how the hell it
happened or what the hell it is you'll
figure it out brother pietro
shows up inside the west view anomaly
played not by the mcu's aaron taylor
johnson quicksilver
whose character died in avengers age of
ultron but by
evan peters who played max moff aka the
mutant quicksilver from
you know i just realized i rewatched
godzilla the other day which had aaron
taylor johnson and elizabeth olson both
aaron taylor johnson
and evan peters peter's right start kick
ass together yeah they both played
quicksilver
so many connections multiverse
previously separate film universe the
fox x-men franchise
properties that are now all owned by
disney and therefore under the same ip
umbrella as marvel studios the avengers
movies
and wanavision so are we looking at the
first official on-screen crossover
between the mcu
and this x-men universe of wolverine
deadpool multiple magnetos professor
go whatever you say stunt casting and a
meta joke about sitcom recasting
designed to fool wand maximoff
and to fool us or to quote this witch a
bit of both
i'm gonna explain how quicksilver got
here and what his cameo tells us about
the mcu's plans
to bring the x-men into mcu so
quicksilver has had one of the more
confusing on-screen histories of the
marvel film characters
in the comics he's a speedster mutant
brother to scarlet witch both the
children of magneto in the 90s marvel
comics sold the film rights of the x-men
to
fox studios and that first 2000 x-men
was actually kevin feige's start in this
genre
he was an associate producer on the film
first appearance in these movies
technically what i did
listed outside
but then years later evan peters was
cast as quicksilver in 2014's days of
future past a pretty great film that
bridges both eras of the x-men movies
wolverine goes back in time to the 1970s
to prevent a post-apocalyptic future
with the new x-men characters that
includes them using quicksilver to break
out magneto from the pentagon
amazing time in a bottle sequence they
do bring up magneto being his dad but
they don't dwell on it now around this
time kevin feige had grown marvel
studios from an independent studio that
would sometimes partner with other
studios and co-licensed characters to
a goliath now owned by disney and this
is just in time for avengers age of
ultron in which they hope to feature the
maximoff twins
but then fox was like ah no way
quicksilver is now our hottest rookie so
if you want to use him you cannot make
him an avenger you cannot mention his
magneto connection and you cannot once
say the word mutant so joss whedon's
scripts kind of had to awkwardly use
words like
enhanced for the maximum of twins and
then avoided saying quick silver
altogether
and then permanently cut off oh they
just did
say quicksilver meanwhile fox kept
producing x-men movies each
set in a later decade wait a minute is
the implication
that they killed him off not just for
story purposes but because
of the fact of the connection to the fox
world oh
maybe how deep does the rabbit hole i'm
actually
very unfamiliar with all this i mean i i
heard that they couldn't say the word
mutants but this whole thing with
aaron taylor johnson not being able to
become an avenger was actually because
of a business decision
that was affected by the fact that evan
peters was quicksilver in x-men i could
see it being that way
especially with how much that character
popped off when they introduced that's
why disney bought your ass [ __ ]
one scarlet witch in the last episode of
one division they said she doesn't have
her name yet her code names
that tracks with this too fox kept
producing x-men movies
each set in a later decade 60s 70s 80s
90s sound familiar well hold that
thought now the 80s set x-men apocalypse
is memorable mostly for another
quicksilver scene you save dozens of
mutant students from the x-mansion as it
explodes he moves at insane god level
speeds he's basically stopping time it's
all set to the eurythmics sweet dreams
pretty cool but around this time the
tides were turning
deadpool really became the dominant
moneymaker for fox marvel studios
cinematic universe was
growing more and more interconnected it
became the center of the nerd movie
universe
and the last vestiges of the old x-men
brand really came to a close with logan
in 2017
and fox seeing the writing on the wall
sold all of its film rights to disney
but they had already shot this 90 set
x-men dark phoenix
so by the time they released it in 2019
everyone was like is this still
happening
quick silver is barely in the movie the
movie's not great really you could sense
that behind the scenes the studio was
just kind of like waiting for this
franchise to die off so that they could
like sword vision yank apart this corpse
and reboot it for bigger and better
things
and one of those projects is evan peters
crossing the stream size quicksilver
here in wan division
but he didn't cover how x-men apocalypse
a big part of that movie is quicksilver
wants to confront magneto
actually confront his father you know
that we have this theory about who might
be a big cameo professor actually
magneto and i kind of feel like you have
a confrontation yeah you can wrap it up
and maybe that's why he wants to connect
with his sister i guess i'm just saying
i'm just saying
i'm just saying by what logic is marvel
studios introducing the x-men in the mcu
what does this mean well let us remind
ourselves of really the four
paths marvel might be using to reboot
the x-men and see how this quicksilver
cameo fits in with it all
theory one the explanation i think most
of us are thinking is gonna be the case
quicksilver came from the multiverse
yeah so avengers end game reset the mcu
on kind of an axis
of multiple branch timelines aka the
multiverse you'll remember spider-man
far from home
mentioned this multiverse but it was
then revealed to be mysterio's lie
yet the multiverse exists one division
could be part of a multiverse saga a
multi-title event
spider-man 3 will similarly cross over
characters from past alternate universes
and team up peter parker with multiverse
navigator doctor strange
and doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is going to be some kind of
multiverse plot based on the title
in which wanda is confirmed to
restructure most believe as the villain
so what we're looking at with this
westview anomaly and maybe a kind of
window to that multiverse
i want to just say i don't think uh
wanda will necessarily be like a
bad guy but perhaps embody some type of
antagonistic
problematic role just for motivation at
odds with everybody else yeah
i don't think he's gonna be evil and
want to be like like evil i don't think
is right a word for this like villainous
per se but not you know like i'm a
baddie yeah does that make sense
an antagonist rather than an outright
villain what we're looking at with this
westview anomaly it may be a kind of
window to that multiverse
all of its sitcoms sets its props it's
costumes it's music all these aesthetics
are being pulled from
alternate dimensions that are based on
real world pop culture
a dick van dyke reality a bewitched
reality a brady bunch reality a family
ties reality
and among all of these pop culture
infinite realities one of them
is the fox x-men franchise because like
the episodes one division each of those
later x-men films progressed decade by
decade
first class in the 60s days of future
past in the 70s apocalypse in the 80s
dark phoenix in the 90s so i did wonder
if eras were the key
brother in this 80s episode the anomaly
plucked a quicksilver from another
universe where he was alive in the 80s
giving us x-men apocalypse era 80s
quicksilver now this does end up being
in the realm of the explanation anyone
from that x-men franchise is fair game
to cross over
deadpool reynolds who is confirmed to
have his next movie set in the mcu
magneto ian mckellen or michael
fassbender professor x
patrick stewart or james boy and by the
way this could be the same logic that
explains how actors like jamie foxx and
alfred molina are reprising their
villains in this new mcu spider-man 3.
okay wait a minute so my question now is
is eric vos implying
that the x-men movies and stuff
are a entertainment property that is
bleeding into
wanda vision see that's it yeah the tv
shows that confuse me i'm like is there
a bewitched
universe by this logic that exists
somewhere parallel to the marvel like a
real bewitched world or is like
she's pulling from the mind of you which
shows is it saying that the x-men movies
are like a movie like franchise yeah
within the not a multi-dimensional thing
but a movie franchise
that wanda has pulled and brought into a
reality
that would be so weird i don't know
about that i don't know if that's what
he's doing
i don't know if that's what he's
implying this is kind of what it sounded
like no no i gotta know i couldn't
pull the 80s apocalypse quicksilver into
the 80s
existing world within one division i get
in my back
wanda maximoff's hex bubble becomes a
sort of interdimensional pandora's box
that spills alternate universe heroes
and villains all over the mcu
and in that way disney just ends up kind
of owning everything but another
explanation for this mutant crossover
that incorporates other elements that
keep being brought up in wandivision is
quicksilver's x-men timeline bridge with
the mcu timeline due to cosmic radiation
one division has made it clear that this
westview anomaly is radiation based
cmbr cosmic microwave background
radiation which they state dates back to
the big bang
the same event that wong explained
infinity war concentrated elements of
the universe into the infinity stones dr
strange movie
monica planning to build a vehicle that
protects from all kinds of radiation so
that she can burst through that wall
radiation including photons and neutrons
which sounds like not
just cmbr but nuclear radiation alpha
beta gamma radiation the deadlier type
of radiation that created the hulk and
radiated from the infinity stones to
injure thanos and banner and fatally
tony stark avengers in game also set the
rules of the mcu so that it's supposed
to be infinity stones that cause
ruptures to the time stream
creating alternate branch timelines
captain america lives out his life with
peggy carter
in one of those alternate histories
recent reports say that marvel is
developing two more films with chris
evans playing cap
and all sides point to at least one of
them following a post-world war ii
team-up with wolverine history of where
x-men could exist i would love that if
the experts do exist in an alternate
timeline
and alternate timelines are branched off
in the mcu with infinity stones
the west view anomaly a hex created in
part by wanda's powers which were
derived from an infinity stone
might also represent a convergence
between those two worlds
not necessarily a pop culture
free-for-all like the first theory
really just two
slightly more plausible realities
bridging due to this infinity stone
radiation i know i might have lost you
there so a more straightforward
explanation for how radiation could have
caused this
english police infinity stone radiation
transformed certain humans into mutants
so
okay the moment darcy sees pietro arrive
if you listen closely a
breach alarm is blaring through the
sword
[Music]
that's right i was always i was thinking
like what is that for
so at that moment someone must have been
entering or exiting west view
this speedster we see here could
fast enough to dirt through the bouncing
particles of the border wall i love that
god level speed he could be one of many
individuals who were irradiated into
mutants around the mcu from one of those
four infinity stone shock waves because
we know in wanda's case it wasn't just
infinity stone radiation she had a
certain genetic predisposition something
that the mcu might define as the x
gene that exists dormant in certain
individuals around the world and has now
been awakened by the infinity stones and
because
that guy is a speedster once he enters
west view the anomaly's rewriting of
reality
warps him into someone wanda would
recognize as her late speedster brother
right
he does not respond to the name pietro
he just kind of tilts his head with an
interesting expression
scans showed up as pure light which
could explain how she was able to
survive her violent expulsion from west
view which was something
damn this is complicated you're
still here
could have awoken from the blip from the
moment tony stark blasted the universe
with the latest shockwave of radiation
and monica rambo's dna could have been
woken up to give her
mutant abilities oh
but i feel like that's an easy switch
for them to make now it is pretty clear
that
wanda did not cognitively summon
quicksilver
i didn't do that it could have been her
subconscious doing it
or this cameo could have been the doing
of the forces
outside of wanda's control so that is
why i have posed a theory that this
quick silver is a trick being pulled on
by
whatever other sinister entity is
lurking in west view but why wouldn't he
bring back aaron taylor johnson then
whoever he is
partnering with maybe agnes herself my
only problem with that theory
is that if he wanted to pull a trick why
would he bring back some other quick
silver you know why would he bring back
aaron taylor johnson specifically yeah
we can risk her not recognizing yeah
like why rewrite him or recast him or do
any of that i mean i can see it being
pulled by somebody else but based off of
that theory
that wasn't really a quicksilver yeah
yeah
i feel like i would be kind of
disappointed if it was like completely a
decoy although i could definitely see it
being something like
ah we found a way to bring in her
brother from a universe
where she isn't there and in this
universe you know we can't get pietro's
real body so we can just pull in a
different quicksilver
exactly and maybe rework his mind yeah a
false
version of her brother in order to
appease her heartbreak
after a resurrected vision is no longer
doing the trick or maybe
fisto is like oh [ __ ] i messed up the
wrong one
now this is true casting evan peters
could mean one of two things that this
entity has access to the multiverse and
is playing a trick by pulling an
alternate universe quicksilver or
reasons that have gone into another
theories
or cassian evan peters could just be
marvel's way of signaling to us
that this is not the real pietro while
kind of winking to the fans in a
meta jokey way that'd be way too
confusing
all the and that less exciting version
of this evan peters would just be for
all intents and purposes just an actor
with an ironic filmography
no i don't i don't think that's it at
all i feel like that would just confuse
the audience
even more so if that's the case you
might as well knock on someone who's
evan peters he should have gotten
someone else
entirely to be so distracted
literally the x-men would never slip by
way too confusing
yeah if this is not the official x-men
crossover what will be marvel's
explanation
well we have to acknowledge folks the
mutants might have always existed in the
mcu remember we don't necessarily have
to
see some cosmic event that births
mutants into existence they might have
always been there just keeping a low
profile in the background of mcu history
maybe fighting thanos's forces from
other unseen fronts of the war
future x-men titles could show us how
wolves who's that guy
i've never seen you before in their own
ways and if they ever did interact with
the avengers these are all just scenes
that happened on the side and the camera
wasn't pointed in that direction
now yeah in this case evan peter says
pietro would have nothing to do with it
and that's why i only bring it up in
case his cameo in one division isn't
revealed to be
part of a bigger x-men crossover because
if that is the case this
they always existed explanation is still
very much on the table but i want to
hear from you which theory makes the
most sense to you
and which would have you the first
amongst them
the first conversation rockstar's
official discord server which you can
join by becoming a patron at patreon.com
new rockstars get our latest obsession
shirt called unusual where's my order
bring it over and you can follow me on
instagram ea boss follow me rockstar
subscribe to rockstars on youtube for
breakdowns of all your wanda vision
confusions
thanks for watching bye-bye all right
i mean the radiation that i would never
have drawn those conclusions that's a
really complicated one right there
it sounds like it's a likely one
especially with the fact of how much
science is being brought up into it
seems like they're really setting
themselves up to have a proper science
explanation with some
occasional mumbo-jargon words in order
to properly justify this happening
yeah but of all the theories i mean that
one seems the most substantial in a lot
of ways and it makes for a good
segue out of everything that happened in
infinity war and that we've seen the
blip so many times it would track with
that too
i mean the easiest one would be the
multiverse one yeah that'd be the
easiest one especially with the build-up
of spider-man 3
how they're clearly doing that whether
without toby and andrew garfield
has been confirmed by jamie foxx and doc
ock already multiverse and madness so
that will be the easiest
explanation you know another scenario
that i kind of thought of was
maybe quicksilver himself he's a
speedster maybe broke
into this multiverse himself it formed
an identity or or perhaps
okay here was my one other crazy theory
that i wanted to toss out there
was that the quicksilver in the x-men
world that is a parallel universe that
is another dimension where the x-men do
exist
quicksilver himself clearly has some
family issues
within that x-men world i mean he wanted
to connect with daddy but didn't
ultimately and you don't ever see
quicksilver interact with ian mckellen's
version
so clearly in that timeline another
quicksilver died before michael
fossbender agent ian mckellen
or he just never actually had that
confrontation had that connection with
him
so maybe they're in the x-men world
maybe that's
that version of scarlet witch of wanda
maximoff maybe
in that alternate world she's the one
who died so maybe wanda died in the
x-men world
and then he goes over here to connect
with his sister
to make it whole yeah it's almost like a
rick and morty type scenario exactly
yeah it's like you're dead in this
reality so why don't we just plug you in
exactly
it's great i don't know that's just one
other scenario that i was there's
a whole bunch of variations because it
was the 80s and then
quicksilver we saw in the 80s maybe just
the universes got super close because of
the decades and he just
fell through because he's here and he's
he's like hey
big he he knows her yeah yeah but she
kind of doesn't recognize him
she at least looks taken aback at his
appearance yes i feel like he kind of
wants a family in a weird way
or maybe here's the other part if it
does kind of tie in with magneto or
professor x
perhaps whatever juan is doing is
affecting the reality over in the x-men
world so they send
quicksilver over there like or magneto
wants his daughter
as well wants his children to unite so
he sends quicksilver over there
professor x
sends quicksilver over here to the mcu
world
in order to try to fix this in some way
so maybe people in the 20th century
x-men world are literally
sensing what's happening here yeah the
other dimension yeah oh that'd be i mean
i feel like that'd be a cool explanation
too absolutely
especially with as much cosmic radiation
and crazy stuff as they've had yeah
lately so there's a whole bunch of
random theories but curious to know what
you guys got to say this is a great
video
very satisfactory subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
subscribe to new rockstars last but not
least
i want to shout out maria hammond maria
you've been an incredible sweetheart to
us
especially as of late over the past few
months i've gotten to know you pretty
well you're a very
kind caring woman you've given john and
i some
awesome presents as of late i hear you
got
more presents on the way for us so sweet
of you
and then you're a big part of the
showdown community we talk back and
forth a lot you're a big fan of blind
wave as well who constantly beats us on
the tv
having your support means so much and
having you constantly connect with us
you have been an extension of the real
rejects in so many ways so i wanted to
say
thank you so much for being you i know
that you would protect us as if
we were your own children so thank you
so much for all the love
all the support mean the world to us and
once there's a proper star wars video to
cover
i will be wearing that star wars shirt
thank you again much love